[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ross tucker former nfl offensive lineman
of course
host of the ross tucker football podcast
westwood one
nfl analyst what do you make of what
tony dungy just tweeted out about replay
well i feel like dan they've done a
better job the last couple years
in terms of what a catch is or is not i
feel like i have a little bit better of
a grasp of it
but there are always going to be cases
that are very difficult and when those
cases come on and you're not quite sure
it's tough to tell
then you keep the the call on the field
you know i'll tell you what i don't like
dan and i feel like i'm the old guy
saying this
that notre dame clemson game and i know
we're talking nfl right now
but we've gotten to the point where
we're replaying
seven plays in like a ten minute period
i mean i was so annoyed
i was it kills the game it kills the
flow of the game
i know we want to get it right but when
we're replaying seemingly every other
play
and that game was like five hours yeah
and overtime was brutal
with the replays just just brutal uh you
know what let me start there we have
brian kelly coming up top of the hour
more likely to play in the national
title game notre dame or clemson
clemson uh because even if they if they
win the rest of their games
they're gonna go you know they're gonna
get sort of the
trevor lawrence didn't play mulligan i
still think they'll be one of the top
four teams
i still think they'll go and while i was
impressed with some of the things that
notre dame did
i just don't envision them being able to
win back-to-back games against an
alabama type of team
you know notre dame has more talent than
they've had dan
but you can still see like when the
clemson wide receivers
are in open space or cover notre dame
still
doesn't quite have the perimeter speed
that the truly elite teams have they
typically have a better o-line maybe
even a d-line that's comparable
but they still don't quite have the same
level of
overall depth and speed with the skill
kids
let me talk about let me get to uh jim
harbaugh and then we'll go to the nfl
because if i always thought jim harbaugh
was a college coach
i just thought that he had fun he was a
rah-rah
corny uh he could blend in he could be
one of the guys
and and maybe not relatable in the nfl
now you get that sense or at least a
little bit of that sense of maybe the
next job
is going to be in the nfl not college
football what do you make of that
i think it's likely and i think it's
because he's never really been able
to solve the quarterback dilemma
at michigan and the irony is right is
that's why he got so much credit in the
first place
you go back to josh johnson at
university of san diego
andrew luck at stanford then of course
with the 49ers he resurrects alex
smith's career colin kaepernick all of
that stuff
but yet at michigan i mean they've tried
transfers they've tried
all kinds of guys he has not been able
and i actually think this kid joe milton
has a chance but he has not been able to
get
consistent performance from that
position and here's the thing dan
it's not talent i follow the recruiting
stuff closely
they recruit top 10 recruiting class
every year
you look at the amount of guys they've
had drafted the amount of guys that go
to the combine from michigan
it's 15 20 a year i mean they're pumping
out a lot
of talent they just haven't quite been
able
to get a quarterback that can play at a
trevor lawrence justin fields type
of level pac-12 is playing at
9 00 a.m local time how how desperate is
the pac-12
i don't understand this at all dan i'm
so glad you brought this up
i think paulie will be with me on this
one i have said for years dan
that one of the group of five
conferences
or an fcs conference like you know
something like with delaware william and
mary
you know richmond they should play at 9
00 a.m
or at least 10 a.m or 11. look the ivy
league game of the week let's bring it
back to my dudes
the ivy league game of the week every
saturday at 9 00 am
you can't tell me that there aren't
people that wouldn't
rather watch that than watch the
pre-game shows
i think playing at 9am is fine i don't
understand how it benefits the pac-12
i mean and they're playing at 9am on the
west coast well okay that's noon on the
east coast where there's already a bunch
of good
acc games big ten games i don't really
see how that benefits them if i'm pack
12
i try to own maybe friday night
at nine o'clock saturday night nine
o'clock i try to get the late window
they're not going to do any damage in
the early window
there should be an east coast conference
though either group of five like the sun
belt
or an fcs that play or at least 10 a.m
even if you do 10 a.m
that's two hours where you would be the
only game
on tv and people still would prefer live
sports
over a pre-game show no matter how good
college game day is
he's ross tucker former nfl offensive
lineman and host of ross tucker football
podcast and westwood one nfl analyst
the saints last night blew out the
buccaneers because
wow it's not even a question it's a
sentence you want me to finish and it's
because they kicked
their butt all over the field you know
that is
that's one of those games dan where i am
very curious to see
whether it's just a one week flush it
doesn't really matter
you know sometimes that happens or
is it a game where the saints are able
to to really
benefit from that and carry that forward
and go on a run here and conversely
does it affect you know the bucks
confidence do they go in the hole after
this i know this though there are years
i think it was 1994. you know i grew up
outside of philly as an eagles fan
i want to say in 94 and you guys can
look this up
the eagles went to san francisco on like
a monday night game
and beat the niners by 20 they smashed
them
the niners still won the super bowl by
30 points i mean it didn't matter
but that happens every once in a while
and i think that what's really important
moving forward
is how both of those teams respond from
last night i've been waiting for that
saints defense all year i mean
they have talent everywhere i don't know
why they haven't been able to play
to that level that they did last night
that was awfully awfully impressive
40 to 8 was the final score
that was that monday night game of the
eagles oh my god was it that bad
yeah yeah i remember that and think
about that and charlie
garner charlie charlie garner running
back
yeah yeah so that's a good i'm glad guy
you got you have some quick stats guys
was that mclovin or was that paulie i
don't know but anyway that's paulie
well here's what i would say about
though dan it's a good lesson for
everybody this morning
to not take any one result and try to
i know look i know we're in the media
you got to talk about the next day
but to not take any one game especially
middle of the year
and try to extrapolate that for what's
going to happen the rest of the season
but ross when did we
start this with we got to start talking
about the mvp like it's the heisman
after
you know after the month of september
who's the mvp
i don't remember doing that until
recently it felt like hey if brett favre
wins it or peyton wins it and
we'll just wait until the end of the
season it feels like this is almost week
by week
who's going up and who's going down in
the mvp race
why is that yeah it's a good question
and it does seem like it started the
last couple years i don't remember that
when i was playing
i don't know i i guess dan because it's
easy
it's an easy thing to talk about who's
the mvp who's going to win the super i
mean
it's something that you can take the
temperature of every week and now
russell wilson had four turnovers
mahomes didn't so now emma holmes is in
the lead
i don't know i to be honest with you
i've never cared that much
about the mvp i feel like for whatever
reason
the heisman is a much bigger deal than
nfl mvp
i don't know why that is but i i've
always been more
interested in the heisman conversation
than the nfl mvp one
yeah but it feels like in the nfl you're
going to earn the mvp
whereas in college football it's you
know
criteria who am i voting for uh best
player on the best team
you know i i i love voting for the
heisman
but it doesn't feel like it's as
scientific as maybe the nfl is
i think that's fair and i think once
something that's a fun
exercise is to go back through the
heisman winners over the last 20 years
and you look at some of them and you're
like wait a minute how did how did mark
ingram win over whoever how how did he
win
because when you go back and do and even
if and i'm not just talking about their
nfl
careers you just kind of remember the
players in college and then you look at
their stats
and you think how did that happen and
usually how it happened
is in november and december the games
that are
nationally televised it's going to be
the best two or three or four teams
and it's going to go to the best player
on one of the best two or three teams
even if andrew luck was more deserving
than i think i think it was andrew
luckenmark anger maybe
you look back and you're like oh my gosh
andrew luck andrew luck carried stanford
to a
a a big win in the bowl he was a better
college football player than mark ingram
was that year but ingram was alabama's
running back and they were the best team
yeah it just feels like their gaudy
stats now for quarterbacks that
you know you there are players who might
be
the best player in college football may
not be trevor lawrence
i mean shocker there that there might be
somebody who turns out to be a better
football player in the pros but if you
put up these gaudy numbers
you're and you're on a good team and you
you go in the final four you're gonna
you're gonna
have a great chance to win the heisman
trophy that's not always the case in the
nfl
well i think at this point dan i really
do based on the rule changes at both
levels
and based on what coordinators have
figured out in terms of the rpos
and the zone reading some of the things
you can do to really put defenses in a
bind
i'd be surprised if there's an nfl mvp
or a heisman winner over the next 10 20
years
that isn't a quarterback yeah when is
that going to happen
it's not i mean look at the top five for
both awards this year
it's russell wilson mahomes blah blah
blah maybe josh allen or
aaron rodgers in college football it's
field
i i'm not sure dan when the next time
we'll have a non-quarterback
win either one of those awards to your
point yeah i'm with you because
let's say barry sanders was playing now
and rushing for 2300 yards
which is what he did is that enough
and you know he he wasn't on a national
title contender
he was on a good team like delvin cook
at florida state was awesome
but an awesome in the nfl but he's not
you're not
playing for a national championship and
it's rare when we single out a running
back or a wide receiver anymore or
defensively i mean
yeah i mean michael thomas set the
record for catches in the season last
year
on an awesome team and nobody really
so in the nfl we've gotten to this point
where
if you're christian mccaffrey or michael
thomas and you have a great statistical
season
somehow that puts you in the category
for offensive player of the year
but not mvp but then the mvp
is an offensive player but he's not the
offensive player of the year i mean
we've totally screwed this up i'll give
you another one
dan nobody's talking about big ben for
mvp
because he's coming back from injury so
we've already put him in the comeback
player of the year
he's in the comeback player of the year
bucket oh yeah give that to big ben
or alex smith don't even talk about him
for mvp it's a joke
good to talk to you buddy thanks for
joining us we'll talk to you soon
all right sounds good that's ross tucker
former nfl offensive lineman ross tucker
football podcast westwood one nfl
analyst